[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
prosecutors in the george floyd case
seek to admit into evidence prior bad
acts body cam video reveals the arrest
of a 14 year old boy who officers knelt
on for 17 minutes plus fashion designer
massimo gianouli reports to prison for
his role in the varsity blues scandal
and a man convicted of stabbing and
dismembering his parents must spend the
rest of his life in prison what he says
he now wants to do to his fellow inmates
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
new developments in the george floyd
case as prosecutors are pushing to use
video of one of the former officers
kneeling on the back of a 14 year old
under arrest back in 2017.
prosecutors say body cam footage shows
derrick chauvin kneeling on the boy's
back for 17 minutes police were called
to the boy's house after his mother said
she was assaulted by her son and
daughter the boy reportedly was laying
on the ground when officers arrived and
did not get up two seconds later chauvin
grabbed the child's throat and hit him
again in the head with his flashlight
the boy cried out mom and appeared to
lose consciousness he awoke a minute
later and said he couldn't breathe
prosecutors are arguing this shows a
pattern of excessive force by chauvin
joining us now is attorney deanna dahl
along with terry austin dina let's start
with you showbiz defense attorney says
his actions were in line with the
department's policy at the time does
that fact mean we're not going to hear
or see this body cam video in a
potential george floyd case
not necessarily because he's probably
also going to allege that the killing of
george floyd was also within the line
within department policy the fact is did
he use a pattern of using it intentional
unreasonable force that's what the
prosecution is going to prove and it's
possible this might come in as that
now terry following police procedure at
the time that sounds more like a civil
defense than a criminal defense what do
you think
you know what following police procedure
is definitely a possible defense in a
civil wrongful death action and we know
already that george floyd's family has
filed a wrongful death action against
the city of minneapolis and also against
the police officers involved i actually
reviewed the complaint and it does
specifically state that the police
officers fail to follow police
procedures so we'll see what happens in
that case but you know i think there's a
good chance that the civil action is
going to result in some you know damages
as far as the plaintiffs are concerned
all right well of course keep an eye out
on both cases the criminal case and the
potential civil case upcoming thank you
terry and now to california where
massimo gianouli has reported to prison
starting his five-month sentence for his
role in the college admission scandal
the fashion designer and husband to
actress lori lockland was admitted into
federal prison near santa barbara the
couple pled guilty to paying 500 000
to pay to get their two daughters into
university of southern california
lachlan began her two-month sentence
back in october gian newly reportedly
shaved his head and grew a beer to have
a tough guy look
the husband of the late actress nya
rivera is suing the county where she
died long crimes angenette has the
details
the lawsuit filed by nya rivera's
husband actor ryan dorsey and her estate
claims that her death earlier this year
was completely avoidable that lawsuit
claims that the boat that she was on
with her son left safety features and
that they fell below coast guard
standards it also claims there wasn't an
adult flotation device on board but the
coroner who performed the autopsy on
rivera said the boat had one dorsey is
suing ventura county its parks
management and the united water
conservation district dorsey said the
lake where his wife drowned also didn't
have signs warning about a strong
current rivera was only 33 her
four-year-old son was with her when she
went underwater searchers found her body
days later ventura county declined to
comment when contacted by law and crime
about the lawsuit for law and crime
daily i'm angelette levy
thanks aunt jeanette and tomorrow she'll
bring us an exclusive interview with a
former fbi profiler john douglas on the
case of a serial killer and white
supremacists
and then one day in october 1980 i got a
call from a dave pole he's a supervisor
in the civil rights division he said
john
we know you've been doing his research
we have this offender named joseph paul
franklin we don't know where he is he
just escaped now from a uh from a jail
in kentucky he's killed over 20 people
do you think you think you can help help
us down and i said really i said
i don't know i said i'll give it a whirl
so they said come on up to headquarters
a florida woman accused of killing her
co-worker at a salon is reportedly down
to just 74 pounds the jacksonville
sheriff's office is requesting emergency
care writing in a petition that kimberly
kessler is trying to kill herself
through starvation she weighed 196
pounds when booked into jail a judge
found her competent to stand trial back
in march
now deputies say she rubs feces on the
windows and throws food when she becomes
mad she had another outburst during a
pre-trial hearing
anyway so i can say whatever i want
we're not on you oh okay
we may want to put her on mute while we
finish this judge
uh it's fine
myself
i want
to get rid of the public defender's
office
yeah exactly jordan beard is johnson's
nephew jordan beard is julia's cousin
sergeant will you just take her back
please thank you
this is another issue i think the court
at some point will happen
she is in fact competent
she certainly is entitled to represent
herself should she choose so you may
need to address that a nelson hearing at
some point
still ahead on law and crime daily a
convicted killer points to finger at his
ex-wife who's really
[Music]
a tennessee judge ordered joel guy jr to
spend the rest of his life behind bars
for stabbing his parents to death on
thanksgiving weekend
law enforcement found his parents
dismembered body parts scattered
throughout their home his mother's head
in a pot on the stove his father's hands
on the bathroom floor and their torsos
were soaking in barrels full of acid he
was convicted and sentenced to life for
murder the judge ordered he serves the
maximum sentence for abusing their
corpses
just before guys sentencing we learned a
shocking admission made by the defendant
terry austin has more
ryan i've obtained a copy of a letter
joel guy jr wrote to the court i have to
say it's truly remarkable he writes i'm
having fantasies of using my fingers to
gouge this gentleman's eyes out of his
head while he's unconscious and
therefore wouldn't defend himself the
defendant goes on to say he would be a
threat to the general jail population
and that he's psychologically unstable a
spokesperson for the jail says he's in
isolation and is only allowed out of his
sail for one hour a day
the victim's grandson spoke about the
impact the murders had on the family
my papal he won't be able to ever see
her get married or my mom get married
or me and my brothers graduate
but in the end we all push harder
because we know he is watching at the
end of the day
we are all family
in the bible that says and we stand
praying if
you hold anything against anyone forgive
them
so that your father in heaven forgives
you of your sins
with that being said i forgive
yes all of our lives have been changed
and there is hate
and there has
been many tears to the point where i can
barely even cry anymore
but nothing can be changed they are gone
and i believe with my whole heart
they're in a better place together
the judge said the defendant was pure
evil and beyond rehabilitation
mr guy was stabbed 42 times
in his torso and this guy over 30 times
this was
a crime of i want to say anger but i'm
not sure it was this was just a crime of
this pure evil overkill
and he
was sending a message to his parents and
perhaps in his family through his
actions
and then the steps that he took to try
to dispose of their bodies
was beyond anything that would be
necessary to form a piece of corpse
and so i certainly find that the
circumstances in this case were
aggravated
wow so terry this isn't the first letter
the courts have received from guy junior
what are reactions to this letter
you know i think he's just doing this as
a ploy to keep his cell without a
roommate you know he wrote an earlier
letter saying he wanted the death
penalty because he thought with that
would keep him in a cell without a
roommate and the judge didn't you know
buy that and the judge said this was
just a maneuver and so i don't think the
judge is going to buy this either but i
will tell you something brian i think
they're going to keep him in a cell by
himself no matter what absolutely so
terry thinks it's a ploy but dina we
know the prison has to take it seriously
at least for the sake of the other
inmates do you think as as terry believe
this is a ploy uh to kind of get his own
space or do you truly think he has these
murderous thoughts
i agree with terry this seems to be a
ploy for one thing he does not have a
cellmate so when he says i want to gouge
them out when they're sleeping it's a
complete lie
and his family has said he is
intelligent he is manipulative he's
clearly here trying to manipulate the
system but the system does have to take
this seriously because they do need to
protect the other inmates
you know so you don't want to see
somebody like this who's committed such
a horrific crime get his way but he
might
yeah i definitely got to play it safe
because the last thing you need is a
couple eyeless inmates because of this
defendant thank you both still ahead the
murder trial pizza order at domino's to
lure biggs to her death
i remember
her saying somebody else's name
i remember it was a
i was still over by the tree were the
kids all still in the car when she made
the phone call
yes sir as far as you know did the kids
ever leave the car
no sir
cobb says he was outside next to a tree
when stefanko placed a fake pete's order
he says he watched as big's car pulled
up to where they were waiting
with everything that was going on
looking back
she wasn't happy to
see me that's for certain
what did you do
with
ashley's body
when
i had to leave
i picked her up and put her in the car
whose car
ashley's car
in the back seat and when you put her in
the back seat did she have anything on
her that that was placed on her
that she didn't have on her when she
arrived yes there was
a zip tie
how many
i only remember one
i remember one around her neck
cobb says he loaded the victim's body
into her own car and drove her to a
bridge behind his parents house
it's it's our bridge and and
that's why i drove there uh
it's very difficult to explain
that was that that's it's a very that
was a very difficult night
uh i was at the bridge for a moment
erica was behind me and
i just i kept driving through the corn
field until i couldn't drive anymore
where the image is panning i kept
driving down the edge of the field until
i couldn't go any further if i told you
that her vehicle was located in this
little section right here would that
would you have any reason to disagree
with that
no sir
i
parked the car and
i i left i started walking back up
towards the bridge
when we come back is this confessed
killer telling the truth a major
revelation on cross and our analysis
after the break
[Music]
an ohio man who confessed to killing his
ex-girlfriend took a plea that spared
him the death penalty but now chad cobb
says he wasn't the only one involved in
the death of ashley biggs
erica stefanko is on trial for the
murder of a retired army veteran ashley
biggs under cross examination cobb says
he wasn't the one that killed her
was ashley
in her car when
i drove it to
our bridge
in the field yes
yes sir was ashley already dead
yes sir
did you strangle her
i am not the one that strangled her sir
i see
so now you play guilty
and now you're saying that
you didn't kill her is that right
yes sir
you drove the car to the far end of a
cornfield correct yes sir
that cornfield was pretty far off the
road true
yes sir i i don't know
how
uh how far but a decent walk
the defense pointed out that cobb only
implicated stefanko after she filed for
divorce from him leaving him for his
friend and former boss
sir the time and still currently
i'm under a life sentence so
them getting married really neither here
nor there i mean one part
did you
and erica
ever plan
to kill
ashley biggs
no sir
at your sentencing when judge jones
asked you if you had anything to say
did you say anything
about
erica
i told the judge that there is a lot
that i need to say about this but
there's very little that i can
mr cobb
yes sir i'm asking you specifically at
sentencing
did you ever
mention
during your sentencing allocution
anything about erica lyon
again i said that there's a lot of
things that need to be said but there's
so little that i can at that time
cobb's seven-year-old daughter allegedly
was in the car at the time she's now 15
so we're not going to show her face but
she says she remembered hearing the
defendant order a pizza
she was mentally abusive and physically
i remember she would hold me on the
ground
and she would hit me
and then she also before made me eat dog
feces
do you know why she made you eat dog
feces because she was jealous of my
relationship with my father
do you have a memory
of erica
making a phone call yes
she i can remember
her
and i remember hearing it but not seeing
it
and
i know she ordered a pizza
i don't remember what she said that was
on it
and i can remember that she did not use
her name
do you remember what name she did use no
do you know where you were when you
heard this phone call being made
in the back of a car
so
it was you
you said casey al
erica
and was there anyone else
that's all i that's all i recall
remembering seeing
dina let's start here as a defense
attorney you can't plan or prep
for uh for a witness to take the stand
who pled guilty to murder and now says i
didn't murder the person
how do you think the courtroom reacted
to that and how would you react to that
as a defense attorney
it's a prize for the defense attorney
because there's very little evidence
linking the defendant to this crime a
big piece is this
man saying that she was a part of the
crime his whole credibility now has been
called into question because
like you said he's already pled guilty
to the crime why now he's saying he
didn't do it you as a juror you may just
dismiss outright everything he's saying
i mean
literally terry i can see the defense
attorney looking through their notes
being like oh you didn't commit the
crimes forget my cross-examination let's
let's go down this rabbit hole but let's
address the elephant in the room cop
pled guilty to murdering ashley biggs
now he's saying he didn't
where do you think the defense gets to
go with this on summation
you know here's what i'm going to say
liar liar pants on fire i agree with
dina you know one lies enough to
question anything he has said and to
question all the truths that he said
there's no question in my mind that
cobbs absolutely murdered ashley biggs
or else he would not have pled guilty to
it and you know while i think erica
stefanko was definitely involved and she
definitely made that call and lured
ashley to the scene she wasn't the one
to kill her and i think what the defense
is going to say is look you can't
believe anything this individual has to
say so obviously my client meaning the
defendant wasn't involved in this so i
think it really helped the defense and
it really absolutely hurt the
prosecution here
dina i know it's like kind of a small
detail but i feel like it's playing a
big part here in the trial this whole
pizza order you've got cobb saying it
was half pepperoni half mushroom and
that's what kind of threw him off you've
got the daughter saying
you know what i don't remember it but i
remember a pizza order which seems to be
a weird thing to remember when you're
six and someone else said it was all
pepperoni i think it was a pizza manager
with these different stories not really
lining up where does that leave stefanko
like you said it's very odd you know
criminal trial is going to hinge on a
pizza order if i'm a juror i'm going to
dismiss actually a lot of that i mean
it's possible the daughter saying she
heard it is probably the most relevant
here whether or not you believe a child
at seven years old like you said it's
gonna remember that so distinctly seven
years later you don't know right that's
why there's not a ton of evidence here i
don't think they're gonna convict or not
solely based on that daughter's
testimony they're gonna find have to
find something else also linking her to
the crime uh thank you for joining us
here at the long crime daily everyone
make sure to come back to talk about
justice in america
[Music]
you